we are going to look at part two of
Carrie Lake versus Piers Morgan now this
is a I find these conversations
genuinely interesting I'm not a big
Piers Morgan fan and as I've said before
uh I I now just ignore requests from his
show to be on because they've now like
four times
David can you be on in two hours we're
gonna send a little and then it's just
like gets canceled you know five minutes
before and it's just a waste of
everybody's time I find them
unprofessional I think that the show is
kind of a mess but every once in a while
Pierce does a really good interview
last time that um Piers Morgan
interviewed Carrie Lake who of course
lost her gubernatorial race in Arizona
uh she really made herself out to look
like a fool and she was in London um
over the weekend or over the last few
days she did another interview with
Piers Morgan and these go so terribly
and of course I don't think Carrie like
realizes it she promotes it as I face
down Piers Morgan or whatever appears
Morgan accurately tells her listen stop
going back you you lost in 2020.
wouldn't it be better I'm sorry 2022
wouldn't it be just better to stop
talking about how Trump won 2020 and
stop talking about how you won 2022. you
guys didn't win and look forward and
Kerry Lake apparently doesn't agree
because she's got to keep the grift
going you and Trump both refused to
accept the result of democratic
elections and I say to you in all
sincerity I think it's a it's a it's a
vote losing premise that's fine to keep
saying I didn't lose when you did you're
better off going I lost that time next
time I'm going to win I totally
understand that I understand what you're
saying and I would just ask this when
you voted when was the last time you
voted right here yes uh in the last
election okay so you voted if you'd
shown up and they said you're gonna wait
five hours and 61 of the polling
locations had function non-functioning
equipment none of this is true remember
you waited five hours you showed up to
vote and the tabulator refused your
ballot and they said you know what go
down the road would you be okay with
that you have to approval we have proven
you haven't proven that you have proven
it you haven't it's been independently
established you haven't proven it was
allegations I wish you were there you
say you were robbed Trump says look
Trump in the face and I've liked Donald
personally a long time but I said to him
I don't know why you keep saying you won
the 2020 nobody wants to go back because
they think they raise money on it I
don't know if they still do look forward
offer America
I'm a reason to vote to votes times
yeah listen I agree completely with what
Piers is saying and it really does seem
you know there was a while where it
seemed like it was actually good
strategy to keep harping on that and
there was a while where the balance
seemed clear you're attracting more
people and money than you're turning off
by continuing to talk about how you were
robbed even though many Republicans
still do believe Trump won in 2020 and
some believe Carrie Lake won in 2022. at
this point it seems like it's becoming
increasingly a net negative because it
just doesn't offer a vision of anything
and what's even more delusional is that
in a subsequent moment during this
interview
Kerry Lake when she's asked by peers
about listen are you going to run for
Senate now in Arizona
she continues to talk about getting the
right outcome for the 2022 election
again we are now
five and a half months
from the anniversary of her losing in
Arizona and she is still claiming we're
fighting it we're fighting it Katie
Hobbs is the governor of Arizona that's
it but she keeps talking about you want
to be Senator I want to see elections
also my question um
I'm not sure what my future holds to be
honest I'm working right now on our
election case that's the center of my
would you like to be senator of Arizona
and and if for some reason we don't get
a fair outcome in our election I won't
run for Senate most likely you will most
likely so you're declaring now no I'm
saying most likely if we don't have a
fair outcome in now of course she's not
going to be crowned governor of Arizona
so I guess she's saying she's going to
run for Senate she calls it getting a
fair outcome what she means is somehow
stealing somehow kicking Katie Hobbs out
of office which is not going to happen
Katie Hobbs is the governor
um so I guess she's saying she's going
to run for Senate our election case that
I may consider running for Senate Donald
Trump says she wants you to be his
running mate what do you say we've had
this conversation come on I said if the
royal family invites you in and they
want you to come in I said yes you said
yes
I don't think president Trump needs a
vice president he's that powerful
that's a cop that's a cop-out if I've
ever heard one we know Carrie is
desperate to be Trump's VP desperate
desperate to be Trump's VP but that's
really something Trump is so good
he doesn't even need a vice president
wow there's an idea if you're wrong he's
that powerful as a leader he doesn't
really need one but I do hope he picks
somebody who the media fears more than
they fear him is that you and you know
why I think he should do that because
then they'll stop trying to take him
down
all right so I mean you can get the gist
of just how completely debased and
disconnected from reality Carrie lake is
we'll look at one more clip of this in
this one
um Kerry Lake pulls out the big pharma's
controlling everything thing and this is
the context of saying we can't really
talk about the truth of vaccines it's an
anti-vaxx rant riddled in an
anti-corporate round she can't talk
about big Pharma just like you can't
talk about the music industrial complex
because they control the media
controls me you cannot talk about big
Pharma famously nobody controls me you
cannot know you can't talk about big
Pharma right now you can't talk about
how dangerous the vaccines are well but
that's not true you can't talk about I
don't think the vaccines were dangerous
really no you're not seeing some of the
consequences no I think the vaccines
actually were a remarkably safe okay
let's talk about something we could
probably agree on yeah the vaccines were
remarkably safe I wish they worked
better at preventing transmission
but the vaccines were extraordinarily
safe and so this is this is a common
refrain so this you really have to go
beyond just a single sentence and delve
into this whole big Pharma controls sort
of thing it is absolutely true
that pharmaceutical companies are large
advertisers on TV most countries don't
even allow direct to Consumer
advertising uh you know do you feel
tired in the morning you might be
suffering from what right they spend a
ton of money advertising their products
they spend money with pharmaceutical
replica that's all absolutely true they
are profit driven all of those things
are absolutely true and also the scale
of pharmaceutical companies has led to
incredible advances in our ability to
treat and in in some cases I wish it
were more prevent disease uh keep people
alive in circumstances where they
previously would have died like that's
all all of these things can be true at
the same time
but there are numerous examples of
investigative journalism news
organizations doing in-depth uh
investigations into the practices of
pharmaceutical companies we've seen
what's happened over the last 10 years
with reports about opioids and um the
the ways in which the pharmaceutical
companies have lobbied and pushed for
more prescribing even though they knew
that these were highly addictive these
things are featured on mainstream news
programs all the time and independent
programs as well in 2020 CBS News had
this major investigation about the cost
of prescription drugs and they actually
interviewed pharmaceutical Executives
industry experts patients who couldn't
afford medications NBC News in 2019 had
a major series about the opioid epidemic
and they interviewed families that were
affected they they did investigations
into how pharmaceutical companies were
promoting the use 2018 ABC had another
one uh about
um uh opioid there all of these examples
so what they want to do
is normally they say let companies do
whatever they want don't don't limit
them don't regulate them whatever but
now that we want to talk about
supposedly dangerous coveted vaccines
which weren't dangerous which aren't
dangerous now all of a sudden it's
you're owned by the Pharmaceuticals and
nobody can talk about it and it's all
everybody's being silenced and whatever
the case may be Carrie lake is
fundamentally not a serious person and
my hope is and from all of the data I've
seen
uh she has a shot at being Senator if
she runs My Hope Is that she is soundly
defeated in 2024 if indeed she runs for
the senate in Arizona much more soundly
than she was defeated by a much larger
margin than she was defeated in Arizona
in 2022 running for governor and quite
simply she lost the person who got more
votes is now the governor and that's the
right outcome the weather is about to
start warming up and that often means
sweating and chafing and sticking sheath
is the men's underwear that once and for
all puts an end to all of that nonsense
our sponsor sheath underwear has
designed unique boxer briefs with an
ergonomic compartment built to keep
everything separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a mill million pairs have already
been sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for twenty percent off the
link is down below